どういうものかっていうテーマについてお話しさせていただきます
で なんでこういうテーマになったかというと
あまりにも世界はこの数字で法律で決めつけようとと思っているし
だからそういうことだから
なかなかこの社会の人間にとってはね
まあいい人間で生活することっていうのは
まあなかなか大変難しくなっているんですね
どういうことかというと
例えばまあ数字で大人だよと決めることになったら
まあどうせ自然的にその数字にはいくんですよ
それはまあ 生まれた人はね
何をしても何をしなくても歳は取りますので
それはストップしないんですよ
ですから 法律で 20歳で大人だよと決めると
まあ誰でも 20歳で大人になるんですね
寝たきりの障害の人であろうとも
誰でも同じ状態になっちゃうんですよ
そうすると 別に大人になるための準備とかね
大人になるための教育とか
そういうのはもう二の次になってしまうんですね
そういうことで 実際にそうなってるんですよ
だから教育もありますが
いろんなことありますが
このまあ 大人っていうのはどういうものかっていうところはなかなかもう教えてくれないんですよ
だから ある人があんたは大人だよと言ってもね
その人はもうそれは何？ということになるんですよ
ですから この仏教の立場から
で 大人っていうのはどういうものかと考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
で こういうスライド作ろうと思って遅くなりましたけど
まあできてないんです 2
3枚しか ですから この
で まあ仏教の立場からどういうものかと考えた方がいいと思います
こちらに書いているようにね
簡単には もし文字間違いあったら直してください
あの まあ簡単には大人になれないんですよ
だからこのタイトルから考えると
大人になるということは結構苦労しないと修行しないと
わかりやすい言葉で言えば
なれるものじゃないんです
それなりには努力しないと
ですから 学校で教育を受けて
何かできるように努力すると同じく
大人になることも一つの我々の課題にならないといけないんですよ
で ただ年取っただけで
学校を卒業しただけで大人ではないんですね
だからそう簡単には大人になれない
で あの ということで この成長というものをね
向上というものっていうのは瞬時に起こるものではないと
そんなのはわかると思いますけどね
まあぴったしと時計は夜12時になったらもう大人ですよと
11時10 11時10何分でしたっけ？ 19分30秒でもまだまだ大人ではありませんと
それで 30秒経ったらもう大人ですよって
そんなもんじゃないんですよ
特に理解してほしいのは
日本でこの成人式なんとかっていうのはすごいつまらないもので
酒飲めるか飲めないかぐらいの判断ですよ
あれは成人式ではなくて
酒を飲める式なんとかというふうに言葉を変えた方がいいんじゃないですかと私は思いますけど
成人式じゃないんです
君たちは今から酒飲めますよという
まあ酒のなんとか もう私はちょっと考えなかったんですけど
アンケタならいい言葉を作ってくれますけどね
まああれは飲酒強化式典ですよ
それしか何もないんですよ
だからあまり大騒ぎに大騒ぎにする必要はないし
神社に行く必要もないと思いますけど
羽織袴とかね 着物とか着てね
あれ まあ飲酒強化式典ですので
道灌の皆さんに行けばいいんじゃないかなとも思います
で そういうことにしたというのは
なんで二十歳になって酒
酒は十八でしたっけ？二十歳でしたっけ？二十歳ですね
なんで十九歳で酒飲んではいけないんですかね
これまたわからない 科学的根拠はあるんですかね
何か だから何も科学根拠もなくてね
一日経ったら酒飲めますよと
だからまあ仏教から見れば
もう全くもう理屈通ってる話じゃないんですよ
飲める人だったら まあ十歳ぐらいから飲んでもよろしいし
飲めない人は一生飲めない方がよろしいし
これが法律で決めてくれるんだったらね
実際にいますよ もう子供頃から酒飲む人々は
別にもう体が慣れてしまって
別に何か問題あるということでもないしね
それでみんな二十歳まで待ってるかというと
そうじゃないでしょうに
もうかなり早く まあ隠れて飲んだりはするしね
それで日本ではただ飲酒強化式典だけも気にするんですけど
まあ麻薬まで使ってるんだからね
その前に で なんでそういう風にむちゃくちゃになるかというと
やっぱりこのまあ数字で
法律で決めようとするんだから
ですから 仏教から言えるのは
これ大変な仕事だよと
大人になるっていうことは
これはもうずっとそれなりに大人になる特別な訓練を受けておかないといけないんだよ
ということは仏教的な立場なんですよ
ですから  ２行目で書いている生命は本来大人ではありませんと
と書いたのはそういうわけなんです
生命となぜ書くかというと
仏教は人間 人間というふうにはもうあまり言わないんですよ
大体言っている真理は
一切の生命に当てはまる
適用するものであると
ですから なんで人間だけということになりますので
それは西洋的な思考なんですね
すべて人間だけのことにしてあって
他の生命はもう排他して関係ないということで
人間至上主義で 人間が何をやってもいいというふうな
それは西洋的な思考で
日本ではそういう思考
なかったんですよ 前は
まあ後で明治のなんとかからまあ西洋的な思考に入れ替えた時は
まあそういう人間ばっかり中心に考えることになりましたけど
昔はもっと幅広く物事を見たとは思います
それは どうなってます？見えませんかな
まあ別に今日大したこと書いてないんですから
別にそのスクリーンにあまり小奇麗でなくてもよろしいというんです
思います 人間もまあ一応本来は生命が大人ではありません
ということは じゃあ皆様方は大人ですか？と
私も自分のことを大人かっていう疑問をいつでも持ってるんですよ
これ今まあ５７ですか ８
になりますけど そろそろ
それで自分が大人ですか？と
まだ自信がないんですよ
それで自信がないままで世界を見渡してみると
みんなもう何もできん人々ばっかしで
そうすると嫌な気持ちになるんで
こちらもいろいろ教えてもらいたいのに
もうなんでみんなにあれなさい
これをやりなさいとか
あれやこれやと言わなくちゃいけないんですかと
そんなところじゃないんだと
そっちを思うんですよ
で 周りにいる人も もう何としてもろくにできない
まあどうせ年下だから
自分が年取ってるんだからね
周りはみんな年下で何もろくにできないし
それでそういう人々の面倒を見るところじゃなくて
まあ自分も何かもうちゃんと教えてくれというわからないことはいっぱいがあるし
ですから 一応年として大人になっても
まあそういうふうに何かまあなんだこれっていうことになるんですよ
だからまあ世間で大人大人だという人々にしても
そんなにも後輩を指導できる自信あるということはないんです
後輩を正しく指導するどころか
自分が誰かにちゃんと教えてくれくれないかっていう状態にいるんだからね
それはもう一つのまあ考えてほしいポイントで
ですから このまあ 私たちもまあもうとっくに大人だよとかね
思うことはもうなんとかやめた方がいいんじゃないかなとは思います
だからいつでも あの 何て言いますか
若い気持ちでいると言ったら
なんかかっこいい言葉なんですけど
いつでもだらしないっていう風に言った方がいいんじゃないかなと
いくら年取っても いつでも青春の気持ちでいるんだぞとかね
なんかかっこいい言葉を言うんですけど
これは私は仏教的に入れ替えてね
いつ年取ってもだらしないんではないかと
ですから まあそういうふうに見た方が
あまり肯定的に見るよりはね
いいとは思います ですから
まあ私たちは年は取っているんですけど
だらしないところはそのままなんですよ
我々もだらしない生き方をして
何をすればいいかはっきりわからなくて
この上もうとんでもない責任を背負う
もうかかってくれるんですよ
自然に いわゆる次の世代を教育させて
育てて 大人にしなくちゃいけないんだと
自分にもできなかったことは
どうやって人にやらせてあげるんですかね
ですから このまあ こういう歳取ってくると
このすごく責任がね 背負わなくちゃいけないし
責任を背負うと言ったっても
これできないんですよ
はっきり言えば そういうわけで
大体誰でもまあ後輩をね
子供たち 自分の子供やらね
まあ教育関係だったら
まあ生徒たちやら とにかく後輩と言えばまとめて後輩ですからね
後輩をガイドする リードする
指導する 育てるというのに
９９パーセント失敗ですよ
たまに成功する場合もありますけど
よくよく調べると もともとその子供が
その生徒がもうもうもともと出来がいいんですよ
生まれたから もう だからあまり手を焼かなくても
もうなんかうまく成長するっていうことはあります
それで私はよく経験ありますよとかね
うまく後輩を 子供を育てたんだよとか
そんな自慢できないと思いますよ
たまたまうまくいくケースも
まあ実際は調べていってるんだからね
たまたまものすごく問題なく成長したというケースを見ると
それがやっぱり結局はその本人が出来がいいんですよ
だから出来が悪い人をちゃんときちんと育てたっていうことは
これがなかなか成り立たないんですね
ですから 年取ったところで責任がもう背負うことになってもろくに果たせない
だから我々も まあ今の現代のね
子供たちと同じく 全くみっともない
もうだらしない 自己管理できない
どうにもならない存在なんですよ
それを理解した方がまずいいんです
まず仏教というのは この答えというより
先に現状と状況をきちんと把握して理解して理解する
そうすると結構もうまあうまく物事をいけるんですよ
それから次に書いているものはね
生年月日っていうのは仏教には関係はないと
それもそのまま覚えておいてください
別に言うことはないんです
仏教は人の生年月日は全然気にしない
それに必要な証拠は後で見せますので
それで仏教は年齢 次のポイント
年齢は知恵で測るものですと
だから目上の人か年上の人か大人かっていうことは
この知恵で測るんですよ
年齢じゃないんです 生年月日じゃないんです
ということは 知恵がある人は大人で
知恵がない人はまだまだ未熟でということになるんです
もし知恵がない場合 例えば測るほどの知恵がない場合はどうしますかね
例えば知恵で年上だと思って
誰が知恵がある人に聞くと
誰も見つかりこないと
もう大変なことになるんですよ
で もう測るほどの知恵がない時は
道徳は基準になりますね
道徳 ですから 道徳の程度によって年上か下かは決めるのです
それで仏教は言いたいことは全部それぐらいのもんですよ
だからまあ聖人 政治になりたければ
立派な人間になりたければ
必要なのはたったポイント一つですよ
知恵はちょっと後回しにしても
道徳的な人間になっているかないかという
だから 80歳か 20 かってどうでもいいんですよ
80歳の人はもう嘘を言うわ
人を騙すわで ならばに
酒に溺れて自己管理何もできなくて
わがまま奔放で生きてるんだったら
もう出来の悪いもうどうにもならんですよ
それで二十歳であろうが
十八歳であろうが しっかりしていて
道徳観があって 悪いことをしないで
人を騙すことはしないで生きてるんだったら
その人年上なんですよ
そこで特に仏教だけの世界ではね
そこはすごい厳しく守るんですよ
道徳的にできてた人が
年とは全く関係なく もう相手に教えたりする
説法するときは 説法を聞く人々はもう年取ってるおじいさん
おばあさんかもしれません
若者がもうこういう風に生きるべきですよとか
何のことなくよ で それはもうわざとあえて実行させるんです
仏教の世界で なぜかで
それは俗世間ではほとんど見えません
それで皆様にちょっとしたエピソードを申し上げます
知っていると思いますけど
お釈迦様が生まれた時
公園で生まれたんだからね
外で で まあまた宮殿に戻って ５
日目ですね このアシタという仙人がいて
そのアシタ仙人がすごい瞑想の達人で
禅定の達人で まあ地球はうるさいと
ということで 自分の瞑想の力で天国に行って
そこら辺で静かな場所で禅定に瞑想に入っているんです
という話 それで彼が禅定から目を覚めて周りを見たら
天国はものすごい大騒ぎしているんです
かなり混乱状態でっていうか
ものすごい大騒ぎ お祭り騒ぎ
天国 天国の人々は それで普段楽しんでいる人々ですけど
それで仙人があんた方はなんでものすごくありえないことでね
特別な祭り騒ぎする必要は天国ではないしね
あんた方はなんでこんな異様なことをしているんですかと聞いたら
この仙人に先生 先生知らないんですかね
この生命を 人類を救う人が生まれたんだよと
だから我々に我々の苦しみもなくしてくれる
究極な幸福を与えてくれるブッダになる人が生まれたんだよと
だから祭りしないでどうすればいいんですか？と
これはもう宇宙ではもう起こりえない出来事だと
だから宇宙の時間といったっても
仏教は光年単位で数えるんだからね
光年というのは宇宙一つの寿命ですからね
ちょっと長いんです だから何兆万年とかはちょっと言いにくいんです
ですから この何光年でももう起こりない出来事だと
ということで それで仙人がどこですか
どこですかと聞いたところで
まあこれはもう釈尊の国で
スッドーダナ王子の息子として生まれたんだよと
言ったら その仙人がすぐ天国から降りたんです
降りてスッドーダナ王子に会いたいと宮殿に行ったんですね
面白いことは このスッドーダナ王子の先生なんです
このアシタ仙人は 若い頃
そこからは全く会ったことも何もなくて
向こうは政治家として活動して
向こうは修行者として活動してとか
で 先生が会いに来ているんだよと聞いたら
王様がすごく喜んで 王様にとっては息子が生まれたことはもう大変な楽しいことで
その上先生も来たんだということで
ものすごく喜んで宮殿に呼ばれて
王様はすごい丁寧に一番格の高い椅子に座ってもらって
王様側は土下座して礼をして
先生に で 小さいところに座ったんですよ
先生の方がすごく偉いんです
国王よりも 言ったらアシタ仙人が君
何か子供が生まれたという話があるんですけど
本当ですか？と言ったら
それそれに来たんだから
さらに喜んで その通りですと
子供が生まれたんだよと
じゃあ私に見せてくれと言ったら
もうもう若い頃しか会ってない先生がね
せっかく来て 自分の子供いたって言えば
それほど父親にとってはね
喜ばしいことはないし
だからさっさと中に入って子供を抱っこしてくるんですよ
子供を抱っこしてきて
子供にこう言うんですね
赤ちゃんだから別に知ってるかどうか分かりませんだけど
これは私の先生だよと
ですから ちゃんと礼をしてしなさいよとかね
ちゃんと先生に礼をしなさいというふうに言いながら
先生に子供を見せたんですね
先生のところにこういう子供を下がって見せようと思ったところで
この菩薩 悉達太子のおじの足がターバンあったそこに引っかかったんです
それすごい失礼なんですよ
で それはしょうがないんだからね
もしかすると お父様がかなり慌てていたというかね
あまりにも感動ばっかりしてでね
親ばかの状態になってた可能性もありますしね
まあどう見たっても あのスッドーどのうちも結構親ばかなんですよ
息子のことならもう何でも正しいという立場でいたんだから
それで仙人がこの悉達太子の足の裏を見てね
たちまち自分座っていた椅子から立ったんです
さっさと立ったんです
立って 父親が先生に礼をしなさいと言っているのに
あの先生は何のこともなく
そのまま土下座させて横に礼をしたんです
赤ちゃんに すごい丁寧
で 父親にとってはもう何もわからなくなっちゃった
どういうことか 自分がものすごく尊敬している
自分の先生が自分も座らないんだから
先生と一緒に同席しない
それぐらい偉い尊敬に値する
このアシタ仙人が全くもう何のことなく
もう地面に膝をつけて
肢体をつけて礼をした
しかし 父親というと スッドーどのよう
お釈迦様の父親だからね
まあ智慧がないわけじゃないし
その瞬間で考えたんですね
自分の息子はまあ並大抵なものではありませんと
それですぐ息子を別なところに置いといて
自分も父親なんですけど
私も我が息子に礼をしますと
何のことなく先生やったことは同じことをしたんです
それはっきりと発言して
父たる私は我が息子に礼をしますと
そういうふうにエピソード
お釈迦様に対してはね
だから実際はそれ起きたかないかっていうことは
あんまりお釈迦様は個人的なことは言いふらさないし
で ただ父親は褒めることは褒めてはいますけど
あの父親はもうどうしようもないという感じでね
私のことになると もう完璧に信頼するんだよとか
それは言ってはいるんですけどね
そういうふうに 3回礼をした話があるんです
それは何を意味するかというと
インド文化っていうのは
この目上の人を尊敬するということは
この中国の道教というんですか
まあ儒教ですね まあ似ているとよりも厳しいんですよ
すごい厳しい 年上の人はもう絶対的な権限を持って尊敬に値するということで
だからこのそういう世界で信じられない
兄弟の中でも上の兄弟が下の兄弟を
上の兄弟にちゃんと礼を挨拶しなくちゃいけないんですよ
年上の兄弟が来ると ちゃんと椅子から立たなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから そういう文化で父親が息子に礼をするというね
だから そのエピソードで我々に何を教えていますかというと
年じゃないんだよということなんです
決して年じゃないんだと
息子も父親もないんだと
この世の中に ないということは
この変な意味ではなくて
息子だから何でも父親のことを聞くべきやとかね
息子は完全に父親に礼をしなきゃ
そんなことではなくて
やっぱり大人は大人 たとえ赤ちゃんであろうとも
なぜならば 菩薩は道徳的にすべて完成してから人間に生まれるでしょうに
修行を完成してから人間に生まれたでしょうに
だから生命としては備える
備えるべきものをすべて一切備えていて生まれたんですよ
だから悟ってもなくても
もう完全たる人間ですから
それで年上と だからそういうエピソードにしたっても
教えているのは この仏教は年齢で年代を測りませんということなんです
で ちょっと次に行きますか
こちらはちょっとダンマパダから一つ偈を出してますけど
ナテーナテーローホーティエーナッサパリタンシロー
この映画があり よき 最後
A かけてください ナテーナテーローホーティエーナッサパリタンシロー
パリパクコワヨタッサモーガジンモーガジンノーティウッチャティ
で まあそれなりに慌てて日本訳を書いたんですけど
髪の毛が白くなっただけでは長老とは言えないと
彼が年老いている 虚しく老いて老いたものですね
老いたものと言えるのです
それから  これはお坊さんに対して言ってるんですよ
だからこの出家した人々が出家して
まあ髪の毛も白くなって
髭も白くなっている そうすると長老ではないかと
たとえ出家して年取っても
お釈迦様はそれだけでは認めないんですよ
すごいけなしてるんですよ
モーガジンのというのは
まあただの老いこぼれやと
敬老の気持ちはないんです
もうがっていうのは 何のものない
ないというむなしいという
からっとというですね
ただの空っぽで老いこぼれではないか
年取っただけで パリパックをわよたっさ
彼の寿命はパリパックももう熟してもうそろそろ落ちそうだと
次 ちょっとどうですかね
定義に行ってるんですね
じゃあ一応まあまた芸はありますけど
定義が出ていますので
定義を理解してから話を続けていきましょう
で あの この成人とかなんとかっていう言葉っていうのはね
まあたくさんパーリ語で言葉ありますけど
この日本語で言うのは便利で当てはまる言葉っていうのはないんです
かなり専門的で まあよくあることっていうのは
バーラという言葉とパンディタという言葉なんですね
バーラっていうのははっきり言えば
辞書を引いてみても 年下っていう意味なんです
まあ年下の子供たちやら誰にでも使う言葉です
しかし 仏教はあえてバーラっていうのは智慧がない人という意味で使っているんです
ですから 愚か者という言葉
意味で使っているんです
そこでさらにバーラってなんなのかと定義した経典がたくさんありまして
いろんな角度から なんで年下
バーラ 愚か者 成人になってないというかということ
定義たくさんあります
あの中でもう面倒くさいんだから
全部一応それなりにまとめて不善しか行うことができない人としたんです
悪いことしかできないと
それが年下のバーラの成人になってない
大人になってない人の生き方なんですね
それで悪いことしかできないと言っても
まあこれちょっとすごい複雑な意味ですけどね
いわゆる自分にとって
人にとって何が正しいかっていうことはわかってない
まだまだ だからいいと思ってやることは何でももうなんか逆になってしまうんですね
まあ具体的な例で言えば
まあみんな若者は遊ぶんだから
まあ遊ぶのは当たり前だと思って
自分も遊びにふけてしまうとか
まあ酒飲んでふざけているのは
そんなのは若いんだから
元気だから そんなことばっかりやって自分の人生は台無しにするとかね
ですから まあ我々知ってる若者っていうのは
もうかなり自分の人生を台無しにしちゃうっていうことは結構見えるし
だから年と年齢しただけじゃなくて
仏教から見てももうバーラになるんですね
仏教から見れば どんな80歳の人であろうが
もう50歳であろうが関係なく
バーラであって年下なんですよ
で 自分がもう善悪判断できないんだからね
それでパンディタっていうのは
反対に目上の人という意味ですけど
パンディタはもう確実に智慧がある人というふうな言葉で
賢者という言葉に意味で使っているんですね
善とは何かと知っている人
そこでこの最終的には賢者
賢者 まあ聖人した人 完成した人っていうのは
やっぱりあの悟り開いた人なんですよ
そこで普通の人々には仏教では凡夫という言葉を使ってますね
それにバーラという形容詞をつけて
バーラプトゥージャナーとよく出てくるんですよ
経典の中では バーラプトゥージャナー
まあただの一般人という意味ではなくて
お釈迦様にとってはこのバーラっていうものをつけないと意味がまとめないんですよ
ただ一般人と言っただけで
だからいつでもバーラープトゥージャナー
頭が悪くて一般人であるという
だから一般人と言った途端
頭が悪いということはもう必ず入ってるんです
このプトゥージャナー
凡夫といえば全ての人々なんですよ
修行して悟っている人以外は
全ての生命がプトゥージャナーなんです
ですから 誰一人も大人になっているとは仏教は思ってないんです
それにさらにどうしようもない人の場合は
アンダーという言葉もつけちゃうんです
アンダーバーラープトゥージャナーと
まあ頭が悪くたってもね
まあ殴ってでもなんとか教えられるんですけど
その中でどうしようもないという人間いるんですね
いくら教えたっても絶対道徳否定する
それでこのアンダーバーラープトゥージャナーという人々は何なのかというと
いますかね どうしようもない人々っていうのは
いろいろいます 例えば
私にはすごい財産があるんだと
私は人生成功しているんだと
元気で何一つも病気一つもないんだよと言って威張って
だから道徳やらそういう精神的なことかと
なんかすごく馬鹿にするんですね
そんなのも出来の悪い人々
不幸な人々 人生成功できなかった人やることやと
聞こうともしない もう世界で有名になって
もうものすごい金持ちになって
もう必要なものは何でも手に入って
ああいう人は世界は羨ましがりますが
お釈迦様の言葉はアンダーバーラープトゥージャナーなんです
どうしようもないんだと
全くも評価していないんです
それ では読めないと思います
でも意味は出ない出ないです
出てないでしょう あのどうしようもない人の場合
お釈迦様はこういうことを言っているんだよ
ブッダマッティダナンマッティ
私にはもう子供たち いわゆる神聖子供孫たちはえらい立派な人々がいますよ
ブッダマッティ ブッダメンアッティということは
ダナンアッティ 財産があるんだと
と言って バーロ 愚かなものはヴィハンニャティ
結局悩んでいるんだよと
あれ 威張っていることなんですけど
私にはすごい立派な息子たち
娘たちがいるんだよと
財産はいくらでもあるんだよとか
ただ悩んでいるだけと
ヴィハンニャティ 自分を破壊している
ヴィハンニャティっていうのは自己破壊しているんだと
そんなことを言って あったいあったろうなんて自分に自分さえもないんだよ
クトゥークットゥークトーだな
息子はどこや？財産はどこ？自分に何かやってくれるかと
何もやってくれないんだと
クトーっていうのはどこっていう意味なんですけどね
いすこやと 子供たちはいすこやと
財産もいすこやと 自分に自分もないんだと
だからこのアンダーバーラープトゥジャナという場合は
このような感じで このかなりこの盲目的で
成人にはなってない で
まあそれは 62 番目  それにつなげてもう一つ意味があります
よーと すみませんと 未熟な人と言われる文句で
で その人とまた違う人のこと
それをまあパーリ語で
まあこれから打ちますけど
何でしたっけ？ヨーバローマンヤティーバリアン
パンディトワーピテーナソーバーローチェパンディタマーニセレーバーローティウッチャティという本物の愚か者でどうしようもない人と
まあもともと誰でも生命がね
本来誰でももう成人になってないんだから
それはしょうがないんですよ
しかし 見込みがある人
大人になるという見込みがある人と全くどうしようもない人は誰々ですか
それでヨーバローマンヤティーバリアン
ヨーバロー バローっていうのは成人していない人のことですね
そう 成人していない人はマンニャティ
自分でよく理解わかっている
バリアン 自分が頭が悪いということは
だからはっきりこのみんな成人してないんだとまず言っておくんですよ
だから我々は たとえ年取っていても
まだまだ道徳もろくにわからない
もうどうしようもない人々だと理解した方がいいんですよ
それはわかるならば バリアンできてないことをわかっているならば
パンディトワーピテーナソー
ワーアピ 確かにそれによって
そう 彼がパンディト賢者になりますと成人しますよ
だからお釈迦様に逆らうんじゃなくて
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているように
やっぱりまあどうしようもない人間だと
自分がまだまだ大人になってないんだと
まあ馬鹿者だと自分で正しく理解しておけば
それによってすごい それだったら頑張るんだからね
このみっともない生き方はどうしようもないとわかるんだからね
それで頑張っちゃいますよ
だからパンディトになります
バーローチェパンディタマーニ
それでまた誰でもバーローですから
成人じゃないんだから
しかし パンディタマーニ
私はもう知ってますよと
もう大人だよと もう教育も受けてるんだよと
社会人だよと すごい社会で
会社でね 重役をやってましたよと
日銀の総裁でしたぞとかなんとかとかね
そうやってまあ自分が知ってるんだよと思っていると
サネーバーローティウッチャティ
その人は確かに愚か者だと
いわゆるどうしようもないアンダーバーラーという方に入っちゃうんです
全然成長しないですね
ヨーバーローマンニャティバーリャンパンディトワーティテーナソバーローティパンディタマーニセウェーバーローティウッチャティ
お釈迦様はそこら辺ではっきりしているんです
もしパーリ語の勉強する方々は
まあ各言葉に意味が必要というのであれば
まあ打ってもらうこともできないということでもないですけど
どうしますかね 必要ですかね
大体 バーローってどうやって訳すればいいんですかね
うん  で 愚か者は自分の愚かさに気づいているならば
それによって賢者になりますと
愚か者なのに 賢者のつもりでいる人は
で まあ確かにという言葉は入りませんね
愚か者のままですということなんですけどね
実に愚か者のままいると
それでいいです まあ一応今はそういう方面で
それでまたスライドありますか？はい
一応まあスライド見せて
残りですみません それで終わりにしましょう
で この言葉ね わっからのまたもう一つ前あったと思います
そうそう またナテーナパンディトホーティヤータバフバセティヘーミアヴェーリアバヨパンディトーティウッチャティ
それでこの聖人と言えないんだと
よく喋るからといって賢者ではありませんと
ナテーナパンディトホーティヤータバフバセティ
まあかなりいろんな物事をよくよくよく喋る
だからって誤解するなよと
いろんなことを勉強して
あっちこっちから情報を集めてきて
ものすごく喋って まあ昔は喋るだけで
今はものすごい書くんだからね
もうものすごい もうシリーズで 23冊やらね
もう 40冊やら出すんだからね
だからって頭いいとするなよっていうのは仏教の立場なんです
本当に頭のいい聖人というのは
平に心は安穏で平安でいられるように育てているんだったら
心は安穏で平安かと それからアヴェーリ全くもう怒り憎しみないんですかと
例えば世界の政治家の方々なんかは
かなり勉強もして かなり能力もあって
知識もそういう立場に行くです
しかし 憎しみ怒りでものすごいもう悩んでるでしょう
んでるでしょ だから仏教から見れば
もう完全なもうアンダーバーラブじゃないというところに入るんですよ
いわゆるどうしようもない方に
ただの愚か者じゃなくて
どうしようもない愚か者
ですから このアベリー怒りがない
アベリーっていうことは
これ 怒りがない 憎しみがない
アバヨっていうのは恐怖感がないっていうのは怯えがないという意味で訳せましたけど
やっぱり自分で怯えているだけではなくて
自分を見たら他人怯えるんだったらとんでもない人ですよ
例えばアメリカといった途端
イラク人がもう怯えて震えるんですね
何をしたって爆弾落とすっていうことにもう決まってるんだから
ですから そういう風な
もうみんな怯えさせたり
あるいは逆に自分が怯えたりするということはね
よくない だからもしかするとアバヨっていうのは
この他人に恐怖感を与えないという意味にとった方がより仏教的だと思いますよ
まあ一般辞書を引いたら
まあまあ怯え怯える怯えがないぐらいの意味なんですけど
だから私たちを見たら
みんな他人がね 震えたり
怯えたり 怖くなって逃げたりすると
なんか私を見たって みんな怖くて逃げるんですけど
それは で  それは私のせいじゃないし
誰も殴ったこともないしね
脅したこともないんですけど
だからそういうね 形見て怖くなるっていう場合は
その本人には本人ができてないっていうことでね
しょうがないんですけど
ではなくて 本当に我々は他をね
脅して 生きてるんだから
なんとかして脅しかけようと
だからあまりにも愚か者というかね
例えば北朝鮮の方がなんとかもう核兵器
なんとかなんとか言って脅しをかける
で こちらもそれで怯えたりするとかね
そういうのは決して素晴らしい生き方とはね
世界は思ったっても 仏教は思わないんですね
だから私がという私という人が
やっぱり見ると他人が本当に穏やかになる
他人に恐怖感を与えない
それはアバヨという言葉なんですね
だから自分の心を育てているんですよ
成長しているんです もう大人になってるんです
だから怖くない存在 実際
我々は本当に怖くない存在ですか？と
他人に対しては 他人から見れば
あの人は全然怖くないんだよと言えるものじゃないんだから
もうまだまだ成人というタイトルは受けませんね
それがお釈迦様のまたまた次
どう言いますかね もう 1つね
ワーッカルナマッデーナワンナポッカラターヤワサードゥルーポナローホーティイッスキーマッツェリーサトーネワーッカルナマッデーナワンナポッカラターヤワサードゥ
なる法て一色きまっちゃりさと
で 日本語前にパーリ語でそのまま訳してみてください
わっからのマッテナっていうのは
まあ一応喋っただけでは言葉足っちゃっていることなんですね
かなり見事にインパクト強く感動的に喋られる
もう話術の達人だけでは
それからワンナポッカラターエっていうのはかなり様相というか
すごいかっこいいという意味なんです
人はもうもう引き寄せるぐらいもう美しいという意味なんです
男性でも女性でもどちらでもいいんです
なんかものすごい強烈なインパクトを与えるほどの
まあそちらそこら中いっぱいいるでしょうね
なんか大勢の人々を集めて群がって見ようとしたりね
スナップ写真撮ろうとかしたりとかね
頑張ってるんですね あまりにもかっこいいんだからっていうことで夢中になっちゃうんですね
そういう人々も世の中にいる
また すごい話術の達人たちもいる
どちらでも一般人を引き寄せるんですよ
それでリーダーになっていろんなことをやってますけど
お釈迦様っていうのはそれだけではサードループをなる
サードループっていうのはパーフェクトパーソン
いい人っていうなんですね
いわゆる不しゃばしい人
いわゆる私は訳した人間らしいという言葉ですね
人間らしいとは言えないんだと
ものすごい言葉足さで
またその上ものすごい様子が美しくて
惹かれるような人 でも人間らしくないんだよ
いわゆる人間失格だよということです
何があれば えーと パーリ語の最後のところを見て
一色 まあ嫉妬深い 嫉妬っていうのは
他人の幸福は認めない
国同士で考えれば 隣の国が経済的に繁栄してもう成長することを認めない
だから何か仕掛けをしてダメにしちゃうとかね
いくらでも地球上で起きてるんだからね
この 30年間  40年間あたり
40年まではいいんですけど
大体 20年  30年あたり
ずっと私は世界のいろんな変動っていうのを見て調べてきたんです
やっぱり誰にでも経済的に成長して平和にいようと思っても
どこかで誰かが何かをして壊しちゃうんですね
ものすごいもう悲しいんですよ
それであのデイリー デイリー読売という英字新聞がありますね
そちらで日本語でもあったと思いますけどね
なんか連続して記事があってね
イラクの問題について
だからイラクは世界で 2番目の石油を作る国で
その権利を取りたいだけだと
取って OPEC という組織を壊したいんだと
だからフセインがいる限りはそれはできません
だから世界 2番目に石油を作ってるんだけど
食べるものはない 子供は死んでしまう状態にしているんですよ
だから まあ北朝鮮はもう何もないんだから
それ理解はできますよ
でもイラクの場合は別にお金があるんだから
豊かになれるはずですけど
やらせてくれないというね
北朝鮮の場合は そういう人々が自分の国を開発させない
国民をいじめて苦しめて
もう死刑をみんなに宣告して
自分の権力だけ握っておきたいというね
なんか人間のやり方っていうのを見てみると
本当にもう 悲しいんですよ
だからこの一色っていうのは
この嫉妬っていうのは
この我々は他人の幸福をなんか認めない
まあみんな嫉妬といえば
この女性たちがよくやってるあれぐらいだと思って
そんなもんじゃない ものすごい大きいもんですよ
まあ大体自分の国でも嫉妬といえば
それはまあ女の持ち物やというふうに思ってはいるんですけどね
その嫉妬も恐ろしいんですけど
まあそんなに大変大げさなことじゃない
自分よりはちょっと隣の女性がちょっと年下だったら
何か一言言う それには
自分の服よりはちょっとかっこよく見えるんだったら
何か一言それに嫌味を言うというね
それも確かに嫉妬なんですけど
それでまあ女同士で苦しみ合ってるだけで
男には関係ない 女性っていうのはお互いにすごい仲がいいと思っているんだけど
本当かと 男はもう嫁面的にすごい喧嘩するんですよ
でも逆にもしかすると仲がいいと思います
あまりそういう男の友人関係の場合
あまり嫉妬はしないんですね
喧嘩はするんですけどね
嫉妬するんじゃなくて
お前に負けるかというふうな感じで
自分もそれをやろうとはする
全くできないとわかったところで応援する
それは嫉妬ではないんですけど
とにかくそういう女性の間でよく見えるような
そんなつまらない嫉妬じゃないんですよ
それがもっとひどいんですよ
だから これ 男にも女にもあることで
政治家にもみんなにあることで
だから世界が不幸なままで
一人前にはなれないんですね
それは一好きということで
抹茶っていうのは物惜しみ
自分だけ幸せで 他人が幸せになることはもう好まないという物惜しみですね
砂糖っていうのは このへつらいと書いてあまりへつらいってことは
私はあまり意味がわからない
砂糖っていうのはとんでもない
このするがすこいというかね
詐欺というか いろんなぐだぐだ悪いことをして人を騙したりとかね
自分の利益しか考えない
自分の利益だったら何でもやるぞというぐらい
もうそういう性格なんですね
そういう性格は立派な人々
みんな自分で持って 自分たちが大人だと勘違いして
で 若者たちを指導しようとする
で 若者たちもそんなこんな格好良いいい人は追いかける
上手にしゃべる人は追いかける
追いかけて ああ かっこいい
かっこいいと それでその人は性格が悪いとわかっても
まあそれは別別やと 政党化までする
いい例かどうかわかりませんだけど
このマスコミなんかは
このタレントのさんの場合はもういつでも調べている
誰が誰と一緒にいるんですか？とかね
夜誰と寝ていたんですかとか
寝てじゃなくて酒飲んでいたんですか？とかね
そういうことばっかし
もう何ヶ月間でも張り込みで写真枚撮ろうと
だからそんなことをして
それで子供にご飯食べさせてるんだからね
まあ悲しいんですが それでちゃんとそういう性格的にはだらしないと
ある人が堂々とバレても
その人のことは全然批判も何もしない
素晴らしいと言うんです
同じタレントの ある女性なんですけど
まああっちこっち遊んだり
裁判もなったり 本も出されたり
いろいろトラブルばっかしなんです
しかし 一言やっぱりさすがキャリアウーマンとかね
さすがこの世界でも堂々と自分で生きていると褒めるんで
なぜかというと みんなの好みなんですね
その女性が だからかっこよくて
確かにすごい能力ある美しい人ですけど
で そこら辺は問題ないんですよ
もうタレントとして 芸能人として
アーティストとしてはまあ
能力はある で 体も決してもう格悪いわけじゃないんです
私から見れば人間としてはもう最低なんですけどね
何もできんというかね
しかし まあそうやってファンですから
日本中ほとんどの人々は
だったら その人の不倫であろうが
わがままであろうが 高慢であろうが
だらしないところであろうが
素晴らしいと言っちゃうんですよ
名前言えないのは残念ですけどね
名前言っちゃうとすぐわかると思いますけど
それを見ながら私は考えてのは
なるほど だから他のあまり人気ない人とかね
そういう人がもうどこかちょっと遊んだっても
もう称えて称えて それで 2
3週間  1ヶ月とか 自分で食べていられるかと
その報道だけで人はもう全く社会に出られないようにしたりしてね
しかし 相手がかなり人気ある
テレビでもたまに出たっても
結構視聴率があるという存在だったら
もうもしかすると人殺しだっても褒めると思いますよ
その人は それはしょうがないではないかと
確かに逃げ 逃げ回りしないで
堂々とも当たったことが素晴らしいではないかと言うとは思います
法律変えるべきですよと
まあ人間っていうのは普通はそんなもんなんですよ
だからもうもともとマーラだから
もともと年の人になってないんだから
もう判断能力はむちゃくちゃで
そうやって感情でもう生きてるんですよ
それでマスコミやら新聞やら雑誌やら
そういう人々が書いたりするんだから
年下の実際のね 歴史的に年下の子供たちもそれを読んで生活しなくちゃいけない
だから世界はどうなるかと
だからやっぱりこの世界でないべきなんです
こんなのなんとなく当たり前のように聞こえますけど
そんなのは実際世界でないんですよ
やっぱり嫉妬深い人は良くないという
まあそれはそうでしょうとみんな何となく言うんだけど
実際は世の中で存在しないんで
そういうブッダの真理と言っていることは
だからもう完璧にこの我々価値観を入れ替えないとね
大体スライドはそれぐらいだと思いますけど
まだありますかね 一旦もうスライドも終わりましたので
そこら辺ちょっと休憩いたします
これ 今まで説明してた仏教の立場から見れば
人はもともと成人ではないし
未熟でしょうし そんな未熟で長生きして気持ちいいんでしょうかね
具体的に考えてください
時々このいるんでしょ？自分たちの子供たちやら親戚の誰か
でもなんかなかなか成長しない
家に引きこもっている
外へ出たくない 仕事をしたくない
自信がない それで年聞いたら 36歳とかね
38歳とかね それで親のご飯食べて
もうものすごい体が大きい大人だから
それなのに親にいろいろ悪口言ったりして家にこもっている人々いるでしょうに
これすごい気持ちいいんですかね
そんなのは やっぱりこの長生き長生きというのは
一般のこの成人しない人々の考え方で
何もできない まあ大人にならないで長生きすると
えらい他人にも自分にも迷惑なんですよ
38歳ぐらいの男がもう外へ出たくないなと
こう外出て出たくないとかね
怖いとか言っちゃうと
それはまあ一応社会では精神的な病気というふうには言ってますけどね
それで私たちはいくら経ってもマーラというあのことは乗り越えられないんですね
だから我々も決して大人になってない
で 大人になってない人は長生きするということは意味があるかと
だからお釈迦様はそれにこう言うんですよ
ヨッチャワッササタンジーレ
誰かが誰かが このワッサというのは年サタン100ですから
100歳までジーレ生きていても
誰かが誰かがワッササタン100歳まで生きていても
しかし あ これ S １つの抜けちゃった
ドッシーロ S 2つです
ドゥッセーロ 何も道徳はない
シーラっていうのは戒律のことで
何の道徳もない 頭ないと心は全く落ち着いていない
心は育てていない 道徳は全くない
しかし 歳まで生きていると
それでお釈迦様はこう言うんですよ
それよりはエーカーハンジーリタンセーヨ
たった日の命でも十分立派だよ
これよ その一日 寿命は一日しかない人でも
シーラワンタス 道徳的に満たしている
戒律を守っている ジャアイノ
ジャアイノっていうのは瞑想しているっていう意味なんですけど
いわゆる心を育てている
だから一日だけでも道徳的になろうと
心を育てましょうと頑張った人が一日で死んでも
その一日の命があの百歳よりも優れているんです
一日で聖人になろうと頑張ったんだから
一日だけでしたけどね
一日で成功する場合もありますよ
ちゃんと道徳的になって
ちゃんと心を集中することできれば
一日でも立派な賢者になる可能性はあります
ですから 寿命が長い短いっていうのは仏教には全然関係ない
はっきりとそれはもう断って否定しているんです
百歳生きることは素晴らしいことだと
それはお釈迦様たちがお互いに言っていることだけで
全然当てにもしない 世間の話は
で またゲー三つ 二つ入れてます
それから時間がないんだから
ちょっといい加減なことをしましたけど
もう一度 もう次のゲーはヨーチェワッササタンジーレ
そこまで誰かが歳まで生きていても
ドゥッパンニョーアサマヒト
これ言うんです こちらに
ドゥッパンニョー 智慧がない
アサマヒト 心は育てていない
歳まで生きていたっても
頭が悪くて心は育てないならば
それよりはエーカーハンジーリタンセーヨ
一日生きたっても立派だよ
パンニャワンタスジャアイノ
智慧があって心を統一している
それこそが大人の世界
もう一つゲーが同じパターンでありまして
ヨーチェワッササタンジーレ
誰かが歳まで生きていたっても
クシートヒーナウィーリヨ
この部分がこちらにもっている
クシートというのはもう怠け者で努力しない怠け者
ヒーナウィーリヨっていうのは精進努力は欠けている
もう同じ意味ですよ 怠けで精進努力には欠けている
それだったら歳いたっ生活したっても何の意味もないんだよ
無駄や 長生きは しかし
エーカハン自由観せよ
1日だけでもヴィリアーランだとダルハン
しっかりと努力する人です
ダルハンっていうのはものすごいしっかりとキツく
しっかりともう歯を噛んで努力するならば
その一日が素晴らしいのだよ
そういうことで あの長いでなんかはね
あまり仏教はもうそんなに考えていない
仏教を考えたらそんなもんです
だからかなり大胆的な思考なんですよ
だから一貫して仏教は言ってるのは
道徳的に立派な人間になることなんですね
それが難しい 何が良くて何が悪いかと大人もわからないんだから
だから大人も大人ではないんですよ
もう一つ お釈迦様はすごい厳しく言っている言葉がありまして
アッパスターヤンプリソ
アッパスタっていうのは勉強していない人っていう意味で
あの こちらはこの早いかもね
アッパスターヤン アッパスタっていうのは
勉強したものを身についたものはアッパ
少ないアンプリソ で 勉強するということはやっぱり道徳的に身に身にするものですから
まあ次はそんな大騒ぎではないんですけど
バリバッドジーレという
アッパスターヤンプリソ
バリバッドはジーレ あまり勉強も何もしていない人がバリバッダっていうのは牛のこと
牛のように太るんだよ
体だけは それは一行ですよ
全部一行にします いいは小文字
それで次の偈で偈ではなくて
あの次の半分 マンサーニタッサワッダンティ
パンニャータッセネワッダンティ
で 読むしかないです ネワッダンティは
そこでアッパスターヤン
あまり何も勉強というか
人格的に何も勉強していない人はバリバッド牛のように太るんだよ
マンサーニタッサカレーのマンサーニ肉だけはワッダンティ増えるんだと
パンニャータッセネワッダンティ
知恵は全然成長しないんだと
だからまあ世の中みんなやっていることは
お釈迦様はものすごく
からかって否定してるんですよ
だから世の中で体力を作ることやら体の成長やら
まあそれすっごい真剣でしょうに
お釈迦様は言うのは牛やと
だから仏教では本当にもう体
体 肉体の成長は全くもうそんなのはもう全然気にしない
だからまあ今は肉体的に成長することはまあ考える人もいて
また痩せることも考える人がいて
もう本当にもうどうにもならない人類なんですよ
１キロぐらい痩せるためにはもう何でもする
しかし 心育てるためには絶対全く動かんし
だからお釈迦様の時代で別に痩せることに頑張っている人はいないんだから
芸はないんですよ これ最近だからね
だから牛は卒業してるんです
今まで牛みたく まあ一応成長すること
体の肉体の成長を考えてたんですけど
後でこれがまたかっこ悪いとわかって
まあやっぱり痩せることにしようと
しかし よく食べて痩せる方法を知んですよ
とことん美味しく食べて
朝から晩まで しかし 痩せて欲しくないと
だから明らかにこの鎖かけてる筋肉にしか興味ないでしょ
そういう人々は我々を褒めるんですかね
モデルさんやら何やらいて
たった 10 分出ただけで
もう 1,000万とかね
ギャラを取ったりとかね
その世界ですよ 我々生きているのは
鎖かけてる肉体にしか興味ない
食えるんだったら人間の肉だから誰も食わない
狼以外と である いろんな生物学者たちに聞いた話なんですけど
人間の肉はものすごくこの動物にはもう嫌やと
食べたくないんだと どうせ虫やらね
まあもう鹿やらもう飛び上がってもう獲物を取って食べたりするでしょうね
で 例えばこのもうチーターにしたっても
この鹿を追いかけるよりは
そこにいる人間を追いかけても走れないんだから
人間はね 簡単に捕まって食べられるでしょ
食べられない 食べないんですよ
気持ち悪い それ考えてみれば気持ちわかるんです
我々もこの逃げ足が速い動物を捕まえたくなるでしょうに
でも そっちから全然逃げようともしない動物なんかを見ても全然興味ないんですよ
カタツムリを捕まって捕まったそうと誰も威張りませんね
だから動物はもう走って獲物を取るんだから
例えばこのナマケモノという動物はいるでしょ
誰も食べないんですよ
いわゆる野生の動物は
他の動物は 肉食動物は面白くないんですよ
あれもうとっても だって枝をこうやって揺すったら落ちるんだから
なのでものすごい体大きいんですよ
だからおそらく生物学者いうことは何か何かもうポイントあると思いますよ
動物は人間の肉はすごく嫌がるんだと
だから人間が放っておくほかないんだから
動物を動物は攻撃する
あれって 食べるためじゃないんです
だからそういう動物にも食いたがらない
狼ももうきつねも食いたがらない
この肉体をね もうちょっと痩せようとかね
もう 5 キロ痩せればとかね
ウエストの方がもうあと 10 センチが痩せれば
あの S サイズ着られる S
サイズのスカート着られるのにとかね
それで何を得られますか？我々は
地球の土を体に入れて
それを地球の土で体を作って
それからもう肉体は地球に戻る
心はそのまんまで あまりにも
悲しいというかね あまりにもいけない生き方してますよ
だから残念なことにお釈迦様はこの痩せようと思っている人に対しては教えたところはないんです
で まあ私が作ったってもお釈迦様非難することになりますからね
書けよと思ったら書けますけどね
ですから大人にはなるわけない
そういう人々は 我々はそういう人々の教えを聞いて
生き方を聞いて その人々が書いているテキストを読んで
それで人生論を作る 私はどのようにして
この美しい体を 45 年間も 50 歳なのに
どのようにして美しくいられます？そればっかりで研究しますよ
なぜ沖縄人は寿命長生きしているんですか？とかね
豚肉食ってるんだから
俺は豚肉食うではないかとかね
しかし ここら辺の人々は
あれほど豚肉を食べちゃうと長生きするところじゃないと思いますけどね
早く心臓発作を起こして死にますよと思いますけど
それは沖縄人の遺伝ではないかと私は思いますけどね
あれぐらい食べちゃうと
それは別な話で とにかくこの仏教はそうやってすごい大胆に
過激的に 世の中の思考と反対のことを言ってる
言ってるということだけ理解してください
そういうことだから 世の中はもう成人していない人でしか構成していない
一人もいない大人が そこで頭が悪いということになりますね
愚か者ということになるんですよ
ですから この愚か者の中でこういうふうなことをお釈迦様は言うんですよ
スジーワンアヒリケーナ
何の恥も知らない人には生活しやすいんだよと
何の恥も知らない人にはすごい楽にいられますよと
カーカカーカスーレーナダンシナ
カラスの知恵があれば
生きやすいと このカーカスというのはカラスみたいって意味なんで
カラスの性格知ってるでしょ？とにかく何でも自分のことしか考えない
他の動物は何でも食っちゃう
しかしカラスだけは絶対自分のヒナを誰にも食べさせない
食べさせるところから人間まで攻撃するんだから
別に誰も興味ないんですけど
飼おうとしたって別な鳥たち飼いたいんですけどね
カラスを檻に入れて飼おうと誰も思ってないしね
それなのにカラスなんかどこかで巣作りすると
そこら辺はもう誰も行ってはいけませんね
人間さえも攻撃する それで同じ時期に他の鳥たちもね
ヒナを作るでしょうに
行っては食べる 行っては食べる
だから今生ゴミ捨てればネット張ってますけどね
東京の方であんななネットを上げて取っていくんだからですよ
あれはネットの間で穴が開きます
それ十分ですよ カラスには
だからそんなような性格だったらね
自分のことしか考えない
生きやすいんだよと パッカンディナーパガベーナ
それからインチキ偽善でいろいろごまかしをして
で 人の前に出るときは一生懸命衣装やらお化粧やいろんなものをして
時々新興宗教をたくさん
日本で 1年ぐらいになると
だいたい４つ ５つぐらい現れますでしょうしね
そういう神の声を聞く人やら
私は仏だそうという人やらね
よく出ますからね そういう人々はすごい
人の前に出ると なんかえらい格好をつけて
手に足 頭 あっちこっち道具いっぱいつけて
そういう風にいろんな見せかけ
ごまかしをしてね 軽々と自分の設計というかね
収入のことをまあ 考えたりする
今あの新しいなんか宗教があるみたいですね
あの人類がこのエイリアンに作られたという
そこで日本人もものすごいたくさん信者さんがいるんだ
で 言ってるのはアメリカの方だから
それはもう日本人が信仰するのはもう決まってますけど
人類はエイリアンから作られた
ですから このあのクローン人間を作るんだそうと言って
まあ 3番目  4番目なんか作ったと
まあ科学証拠はないんですけど
嘘を言ってるんでしょうと思いますけど
それでも日本人の子供がクローン人間を作ったと
もう大騒ぎですけど あれで世界に向けて
ああいう風に科学的根拠もないものを言うことを
あの連中はね アメリカの人々はそれももうよく合唱して信じる
このアジア人たちの顔はね
だからいくらなんでも論理性っていうのは
正常人よりはアジア人が持っていたんですけどね
なんであんなのを鵜呑みにするかと
これはまあ個人的な話で
別に仏教的な話ではなくて
個人的なすっごく嫌な気持ちにはなります
あれほどインチキ言ってるとこはね
言うならば ちゃんと科学的な
こういうこういうデータ
こういう風に言わなくちゃ
まあとにかくそれは置いといて
で なんで宗教だから体は宇宙人が作った
だから何やと私はできないんですよ
だからクローン人間作ってどうなるんですかね
ただの体でしょうに この人々はもうお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
この牛の状態は全然脱出していないんです
たとえ宇宙人に作られたとしたっても
だからなんでクローン人間作るんですかね
今 今我々より次の世代がもっと立派な人間になった方がいいんじゃないんですかね
クローン人間を作るっていうのは
だらしない このもう鎖かけて病気弱っている
この同じ体のコピーを作ることでしょうに
もし私が私に子供が生まれるんだったら
私より健康的で 私より元気で
私より頭が良くて 私よりかっこよくていたいんですよ
生まれてほしいんですよ
それは普通の人間の考え方やと思いますけど
あの人々はまるっきり同じものをコピーしたがっている
だからもう体のことしか考えてない
あんな変なことを何言うかというと
これも妄想のいいところでね
やっぱり西洋ではね 神が作ったと言っていたし
しかし ダーウィンやら何やら
人々はやっぱりこれはどんどん変化して現れたもんやと言っているし
これで困っちゃったな
どちらでもどうでもいいんだから
ダーウィンでも見たわけじゃないし
それなりのもう推測して言ってることでしょうに
放っておけばいいでしょうに
人間が猿から生まれたっても
ヒノキから生まれたってどうでもいいでしょうに
竹から生まれたって 桃から生まれたっていうのはね
なんでそれを正当化しようとするんですかね？どれほどバカですかと
聖書で人間がね もう神が作ったと
それでまた一日か一週間作ったと言ったって
別にそんなに戒律する必要ありますかね
当時の人々は何かエピソード
物語を書いているだけで
面白いと思う人は読めばいいし
面白くないと思う人は読めなければいい
それで済むものでしょうに
それには何かもう科学的な根拠を作ろうと言っちゃうと
まあ神のことは散々世界でいろんなことを言われちゃったんだから
それはもう勉強しない人々にとっては
また研究できないんですよ
もう本当に神が作ったかないかとか
ものすごい教会の中でもあらゆる反論
そうやらいっぱいやってますから
今までね だからそれまた調べようと思う
それは怠け者でやりたくない
それは信仰したい それで神の代わりに宇宙人論を持ってくる
同じことですけどね だから何言ったっても
人間っていうのは牛は脱出できない
豚は脱出できないというところはそのままなんです
だからはっきりと我々は竹から生まれても
桃から生まれてもどうでもいいんで
生まれた私はどのように生きているかと
善悪判断もできなくて
右も左もわからなくて
人に迷惑をかけたり生きているならば意味がないでしょうね
その命には生きる意味も
そんな百年いたっても何の意味もないでしょう
だから智慧の開発しなさいと
道徳的な人間になりなさいと
心の安穏状態を作りなさいよと
他人に何も怯えが与えられない
完全たる平和な人間になりなさいと
それこそかっこいいでしょうに
ということです まあ一応
ですから このカラスみたいな性格だったら生活しやすいんだと
それからヒリマタージュッジは
この世の中ではね 人間の間ではすごく恥を知って
恥を知るということは
悪いことは恥だと思って
悪いことをしないで生活しちゃうとなかなか大変だよ
この世の中で生きることは
ニッチャンスチガレシナ
自分の生活は 生き方は清らかで生きてみるそうと
悪いことをしないよと思って
自分の日々の行為をね
チェックしてチェックして生活するのはすごい難しいんだと
ですから この本当にお釈迦様がおっしゃっている立派な人間になること
成長することというのは
この人間と一緒はね 並大抵の努力のない人はできないんですよ
こちら嘘言わないと言っちゃうと
もうまんまと騙そうとするでしょ
世界は またバカではないかとかね
非難までする そういう世界ですからね
で それからこの成長していない人に対して
もう一つ面白い言葉があります
頭の悪い人だが 成長しない人々は二人
二人いるんだと 一人は
成長しない人間は二人います
できるだけ短くカットしたんです
幼稚園 アナアガタンバーラン
将来的なバーランっていうのは責任
仕事なんですよ 何て言いますか
これはウェイトという意味ですから
まあ将来の責任 義務などに
それはワハティ もう一生懸命持ち運ぶ
幼稚園 アーガタンバーラン
今現在 自分の目の前にあることはナ・ワハティ
持ち運ばない だからバーランっていうのは重い荷物って意味ですから
いわゆるやらなくちゃいけないっていうことなんですよ
ダンマパダじゃない アナアガタン・バーラン
アナアガタンというのは将来的なことについてはすごい責任を持って
まあ真剣ですよ しかし
アーガタン・バーラン
今自分の目の前にある仕事はナ・ワハティ
やらない これ人間の性格の一つなんですよ
明日はやりますとか あるいはもうこれやらなくちゃ
あれやらなくちゃ ああいうふうな
こういうふうなとかね
とにかく将来のことについて考えて考えて
かなり責任感があって
もう腰が動かないほど
しかし 目の前のことは全部もっっぱらが出してもうやらない
お釈迦さん見事に言ってますよ
なぜですかね  愚か者だから
まだ未熟だから まだガキだからね
子供もそうでしょ 大体目の前のことじゃなくて
別なことにいつでも興味がある
だから世の中はあまりうまくいかないっていうのは決まってるんですよ
それからまた他のところで
この世の中で危険が来ると
世の中に危険があるとするならば
すべてこの愚か者から生まれるんだよと
成長していない人から生まれるんだよ
危険 災難 幸い 幸いというのは災難などはね
災害などはすべて愚か者が作るんだよと
サッベーテ・バーラト・ウッパッジャン
決して成人した賢者からは何一つも悪いこと
危険なことは生まれてこないんだと
で たとえで言うんですよ
竹で作った家だったらね
竹で壁を作って 屋根も茅葺き屋根で立派に作っても
かなり立派な建物が作れますよ
竹で もし火の玉が一つついちゃうと全部燃える
何も残らず そのようなものよ
ですから この智慧のない状態はとても危険だと理解しなさいと
成長しない状態 我々の大人にならない状態はとても危険だと理解しなさいよと
サッパティバヨバールアッパティバヨパンディトサウパッドバール
迷惑だと 無知でいることは
また まああるのはたくさんありますけど
まあ一応このバールの人とそうでない人は理解する場合はね
カンマラックのまあ行為見ればわかりますよと
だから頭ができてない人は喋るものも間違っている
やることを間違っている
考えることを間違っていると
それでもうできてないと理解すればよろしいと
正しいことを喋って 正しいことを考えて正しい行為するならば
まあその人々は智慧のある人々ですよと
で まあまとめとして言うならば
やっぱりこの我々は智慧はちょっと後回しにしても
まあ智慧っていうのはものすごい難しいものだから
道徳から始まるんですよ
嘘を言わないとかね 他人のものを全く取らないとか
よく知らない行為しないということは
いわゆるこのいろんなものに依存して溺れて生活しないと欲を慎めると
全くの嘘を言わないと
殺生しないと 噂言わないと他人を侮辱しないと
それから一番大事なことっていうのは
ようにそう真似するか
これ教典 あの ようにそう真似してから
まあそっちを私は使っている
ようにそう真似しかある
これがこの基本的な この
例えばこの建物にも暖かいし
電気もあるし 何でもあるし
しかし こうやってスクリーンに映したりもするし
基本的に大事なことは電気ですからね
電気なければ何としてもね
成り立ちませんでしょ
このようにそう真似すかるには何か適切な日本語っていうのはないので
如実に知るという言葉をよく使ってますけど
それはやたらボートじゃなくて別な言葉なんですね
え？でもでもどちらでもいいんです
理性的に考える  理性的でもなくて
このやっぱり  こうだからこうなった
こうだからこうなっているというふうに
すごい客観的に考えることなんですね
だからなんか兄弟ですけど
如実にすることとはね
でもお釈迦様もあえて違う言葉を使っているんです
それがあれば頭が良くなりますよと
いわゆるようにその真似してからっていうのは
ようにっていうのはもう
まああの女性の体のことなんですから
だから子供は女性の体から生まれるんですから
ああ じゃあこの赤ちゃんがこの体から生まれたと言えば正しいでしょうし
だからそこから推測すると
やっぱり原因結果の論法
肯定に則って考えることなんですね
いわゆる客観的にしっかりと因果法則を観察しながら物事を見るということだから
決して感情で物事を考えてはいけない
流行ってるんだからといって考えてはいけない
流行ってるんだから自分もやるんじゃない
みんなやってるんだからって自分もやるんじゃない
で決めたり そこは世の中のものは正しいかないかと決める基準というのはそんなもんでね
例えば戦争することには
10国ぐらい  10か国ぐらい国々が応援するんだったら
だったら正しいとかね
私は例えば国連のすべての国が全員一致で戦争しなさいと決めても正しくないとは思いますよ
そんな簡単にみんな決めるんだから正しいんだぞとかね
それは仏教は認めません
だから物事はちゃんとこれだからこうなりましたと
そう言うと こういうこういう原因があると
こういうふうなことになるんだよというふうに
物事を見る能力を身につけてほしいんですよ
それがこの未熟な人格を成功させる基本的なエネルギーなんです
智慧が現れるエネルギーなんですよ
だからもう何でもやっぱり因縁にのっとって考えると
頭が鋭くなりますよ 今日
経典から引用を終了したいんですから
えっと ヨーハベダハロビックという偈がありましたけど
見てたんですかね 見れたみたい
ヨーハベダハロビックを読んじゃっていいですかね
出られたと思ってたんですけど
まあこれは難しくなく
ただあの結論として ヨー
ヨハベ・ダハロ・ビク
ダハラっていうのはすごい小さい年下という子供です
子供の比丘であろうとも
ヨハベ・ダハロ・ビク
まだまだ子供 ガキ 小さい
子供の比丘であろうとも
ユンジャティ・ブッダ・サーサネ
ブッダの教えを ユンジャティっていうのは頑張ってみる
実践してみようと お釈迦様がおっしゃった通りに
私はやって僕はやってみますよと
小さな子供でもやってみると
そう 彼がイマン・ヨーカン
この世をアバーセで照らすんだよ
アッバームットーはチャンディマ
アッバーっていうのは雲のこと
雲から出てくる 出てくるチャンディマ
月のように だから雲に隠れている月がだんだん現れてくると
全部光り輝いているでしょ
世界は そのように小さな子供でも
今まで説明したように
ブッダの教えを この真理の教えですから
科学的に本当のことを言っているんだから
実践しようとすると世の中を照らすんだよと
だからもう年はまるっきり考えたことはない
仏教は人間の社会的な立場は全く考えていない
体綺麗か汚いか 全然男か女か
そういうのはまるっきり考慮しないで
どこ  子供の比丘であろうとも
ユンジャティ・ブッダ・サーサネ
ブッダの教えを頑張っているんだったら
まあ月の雲から出てくる月のごとく
世の中を照らすと ですから
たとえ子供であろうとも
このブッダの道を歩んでみると
もう大人ですという意味なんです
だから そういうケースは実際にありましたからね
すごい小さい時も 歳 歳ぐらいの子供たちも仏道に入って出家して
さっさと頑張ってみて
悟り開くと これでお釈迦様は一人前として聖者として扱う
大人たちにこの人に礼しなさいと
これは子供ではありませんとはっきり言うんですよ
だから 歳の子供で もし修行して悟ったならば
まあ相手が歳であろうとしょうがない
もうこの人に礼をしなくちゃいけない
この人から教えてもらわなくちゃいけない
それで教えてあげることもできるんですよ
そういうことで 大人になる道っていうのは
智慧を開発する道 智慧の道っていうのは
世の中の言ってる道ではありません
世の中っていうのは あまりにもおかしいことを言ってるだけで
で 体のことをいくら喋っても
体を捨てて死ななくちゃいけないんですよ
それで我々は体未熟なままで死んで
どこかで生まれ変われる
で それでも心が 心が未熟なままですよ
またどこかで生まれ変わる
また心は未熟なままなんです
ですから 輪廻の中でいるすべての生命はプトゥッジャナという凡夫がもうマーラですよ
もう成長してない もう成人になってないんです
それで心育ちちゃうと肉体と関係なく
肉体というのはその時その時かぶるもんだからね
それと関係なく 本物の成長
向上っていうのは成り立つのですね
世の中のものは この被ったものについて哲学をしている
これ被りものだから そんなに大したことじゃないんですよ
だから二十歳で成人とか何とか
ただの被り物を見て言ってるだけのことなんです
だからそこで日本ではね
この何年前からかな なんか成人式ですごい大騒ぎして大変なことになりましたと
で かなりトラブルってあっちこっちでね
今年はない その同じトラブルを起こしたところでも
この なんていうのは区役所ですかね
そこら辺では成人式やらないことに
これは困ったと思っても
やっぱり若者たちがやっぱりこれ寂しいと
なんとかしてやりましょうということで
一生懸命いろいろ頑張って
何も問題もなく無事に成人式をやったみたいですね
それで前ですごい大騒ぎして
むちゃくちゃに恥かけた人々も
ちゃんと大きな花束を持ってきたりとかね
まあ先輩の成人たちがね
まあ今年の成人たちのお祝いにも協力したという話で
だからといって問題解決したわけじゃないんですよ
それは去年大騒ぎして問題を起こしたんだから
その反応で今年は大人しくいる
まあ来年ももしかすると大人しくするでしょう
でもそうでないのがわからないんですよ
人間はベストだから 今年の成人になった子供たちには
来年は別な人間が別な人間が成人するんだからね
だからそういうそれはよかった
よかったとね 落ち着けませんよ
そういうことで 人間というのはね
まあやっぱり道徳的に大人になるっていうことは責任持つことやと
何が悪い 何が正しいと自分で判断できる能力やと
それが成人というものだと
年じゃないんだと やるべきことをやってはいけないこと知ってるならば
もう成人なんですよ みっともないことをしない勇気があるならば
もう成人ですよ みんなやりますから
やってやりましょう もうと言って引っ張ったところで
みんなやってるんだからって
どんなことでもやるんだったら
もう大人ではないんですよ
だからやってはいけないことをやりませんというふうに言えるところが成人なんです
やってはいけないことはやりません
だから道徳って何なのかと
仏教の定義ありますから
今日は道徳論を喋るところじゃないんだから
とにかくあの まあ殺生しないぐらいと殺生しない
嘘を言えないとかね 他人に迷惑をかけないとかね
で それから物事を考えるときは
いつでも自分のためになることを考える
みんなのためになることを考えるという
この決まりがありますからね
そこで気をつけて 物事を考えて
責任を持って 将来のことをするんじゃなくて
今自分置かれている問題を解決をするっていうのは
まあ成人の生き方なんですね
というわけで 仏教から見る成人というのはそんなもんです
どうもありがとうございます